my guest tonight is a hilarious comedian
and actress
who hosts the netflix series nailed it
as well as
five podcasts good god five
including why don't you date me uh
her new book is called very fat
very brave please welcome our good
friend nicole
byer nicole we will get to the book in
just a few minutes but
first of all tell me you look gorgeous
you look beautiful
thank you conan yes i love regal
and uh how are you how are you doing
these days
you know honestly i think
most black people have had a rough
couple of weeks
it's been not fun but also
nice to see so many people feel
emboldened to like be in the streets
with us to be
protesting with us that feels good but
you know
it just sucks that like another black
man was killed
that was unarmed and woman brianna
taylor you know
it's it's [ __ ] up yep
yep that's a good summation
not quite as eloquent as some of the
speeches i've heard but probably
the most to the point oh yeah would you
say
that uh and i don't want to i don't want
to lead you with this question but are
you
is is the reaction making you more
hopeful
less hopeful where does this where do
you think you are personally
um i think the reaction makes me
incredibly hopeful because
i feel like too many people were
radicalized who understand
that we have been going through this
[ __ ] for
so long for 450 years like the longest
time
we got brought over we we weren't
treated very nicely because slavery was
bad um and then after slavery jim crow
that was awful like i still have aunts
who are still alive who remember
segregation
like that's insane to me so i think a
lot of white people's eyes were open
and that to me makes me so excited like
my roommate
is a very white man oh he's so white
and he was going to protests with me
and was like explained to his mom that
police brutality is a real thing and
it's awful
and then he went to a protest by himself
and then i came home and he was humming
a chant from the protest and frying
chicken
and i was like did this go fully in the
other direction
what is going on but uh it's just
it's really nice do you think maybe he
went too far or do you think it was
still okay
oh i it was chicken nuggets it wasn't
like fried chicken like deep fried
chicken so i was like
it's not super all the way there he's
like just cheering around
but i appreciate it i appreciate that
he's going to protest alone
i appreciate that my white friends for
the most part have not been bothering me
i got good white people in my life
who are posting for each other [ __ ] they
should read
nobody's going nicole what should i read
how what should i be doing like they've
been doing the work my one friend
eleanor
she sends me stuff she'll be like this
protest is happening and i'm like
this is this is an active ally not a
good ally
because we need active allies you can be
as good as you want inside your house
but that's not going to do anything for
anybody
right yeah it's one of the things that i
think about is
and i've been talking to a lot of
different people in the last two weeks
uh who've who've been telling me over
and over again
that black people are tired of
explaining oh yeah their situation that
it's exhausting
and they're saying you go yeah people go
out do your homework
you do the work and get back to us or
or whatever you've got to do but um
please stop
asking us to explain over and over and
over again as if this is a new
phenomenon
yeah it's not new it's been around since
everybody on this planet was born
also like google.com
it's filled with so much information
yeah and yeah black people we've been
talking about it first
like in my stand-up shows i spend about
10 minutes talking about uh racial
injustices and
being racially profiled i mean it is
comedy and it is
funny and every now and again at like a
meet and greet i'll have someone be like
did that really happen to you and i was
like why would i lie about that
it's a horrific experience that i found
the humor in because that's what black
people been doing
for the longest time awful [ __ ] happens
to us and then we turn it around and we
make it fun
and funny because how else would we
survive
slaves sang songs because they had to
find joy
even though they were living this
horrible existence right
right it is interesting that people
think
obviously the last two weeks has been
filled
it started with this horrific image of
of uh
george floyd's killing and we went from
there
but it is amazing to think that
comedians like yourself will be are able
to walk this
this sort of knife edge of talking about
it
uh getting your feelings out about it
but also miraculously somehow making it
very funny at times that might speak to
people
who might not otherwise hear you you
know when you me when
it's it's interesting it's amazing what
comedy can do yeah like chris rock this
has been floating around this i think it
was in his last special
but he was like cops a few bad apples
i'm butchering this man's joke but uh
it essentially was just like what if
american airlines was like we got a few
bad apples a couple of them like to
crash into mountains
and it's like yeah why do we keep saying
that a few bad apples is okay in a
police department
that's no a few bad apps i had a i had
one bad apple in a bowl and guess what
the rest of the apples tasted like [ __ ]
so i think that's what's happening right
right you talk a lot uh you've talked
about
it how racial inequality
can manifest itself in health care which
is something
probably a lot of people aren't fully
aware of they're aware of
we hear about the more overt blatant
forms
of racial inequality but healthcare
healthcare it can be a way and you've
you've experienced that yourself
oh yeah i fully flew off a motorcycle in
december
i was taking my road test and i failed
it in
maybe the most spectacular way and i was
limping and i had this huge
gash in my leg and i went to urgent care
and they took an x-ray and they were
like here's some crutches
and here's a great recommendation of an
ice pack and i was like that's it and
they're like you don't think you need
any more
and then like two weeks later i was in
buffalo new york with one of my dear
friends christy
and she had a sinus infection so she
went to urgent care and then they gave
her like tylenol codeine
a z-pack and like all this [ __ ] and i
was like wait what
and then i started doing literally the
slightest amount of research i went to
my friend google.com
and googled this and apparently it sent
it stems from like slavery times where
people are like black people heal faster
they're stronger
they don't experience pain and it was to
make white people feel better about
training human beings
and whipping human beings and black
women specifically
get the least amount of care we die
sometimes in like uh
awful ways like there was a woman she
was a teacher in brooklyn i believe
she went to the hospital she said she
had shortness of breath she wasn't
feeling good
she thought she had covid19 they sent
her home
she called an ambulance to her house
they said she was fine
and then she made her way to the
hospital was on a ventilator for like
two weeks and then died because nobody
believed her
and they think that black people are
like seeking
narcotics or whatever but
it's i can't believe you took the
hippocratic oath
and you can't look someone in the eye
and just try to help them mm-hmm
so there's there's you're saying that
there's literally a sense that
uh that a white
physician might have that this this
black person does not
feel the amount of pain that
we feel so i don't need to give them
prescribe the really good tylenol
they're not feeling what my white
patient is feeling
correct or they just don't believe us
maybe he thought i was
lying about being on a motorcycle but no
i'm trying real hard 2020 i'm gonna be a
badass
but uh it's been hard yeah yeah
are you really riding a motorcycle these
days yes wow
i bought a motorcycle but i truly only
take it around my cul-de-sac
because i was like if i fall off again
and i actually have to go to like a real
hospital
kovid 19 i don't want that right well
wear the helmet for god's sake yeah if
you're going
if you're going 20 yards wear the helmet
and wear the good
the good jackets with the armor
armored pants now so i don't yeah yeah
yeah yeah
none of this riding around in daisy
dukes we'll talk about that later
[Laughter]
i wanted to congratulate you uh because
uh nailed it you were nominated critics
choice award for female star
that's really exciting it is exciting
because i
am a star and i'm so glad that people
are taking notice
no i'm kidding it's nice it's really
you're not you're not kidding people
love the show you're so funny on the
show and
it's connected you to this whole
audience uh of
i mean kids i mean adults love the show
as well but kids go
crazy for your show they they love you
which is nice
you're speaking directly to all these
young people that's fantastic
thanks i mean i don't like kids i just
there's something about them
you got too many questions there's a
spooky
like a bunch of kids have been drawing
pictures of me and like their parents
are posting it on twitter and i'm like
this is bad why are you sending this to
me
keep this i don't want this we're
already having a bad week i don't want
to look at your kids ugly drunk
they're adorable you've got this great
critically acclaimed
show people love it it's a hit it's
you've got a huge kid fan base and
you're going after
i love that only you would do that i i
want to talk about your book
congratulations
very fat very brave and it is
filled with amazing photographs
really fantastic but i mean your your
photographer your
poses are incredible
some of these i mean i love there's a
picture in here i can't find it right
now if you in front of an in and out
oh yeah i love this book i love you
thank you just i mean we've all been
we've all been there i've been in front
of an in and out in my leopard skin
uh bikini and uh this is really a great
what is your message what is your
message with
uh very fat very brave uh because the
photographs are
alone are terrific but i know that you
you're trying to accomplish a little
more here
a little bit my friend kim knew money
took the pictures and
my friend allison rich was like you
should do a coffee table book and i was
like
okay and then as i was writing it i was
like it's so dumb that people call fat
women brave for wearing bikinis
so i was like why don't i just make fun
of that whole
weird phenomenon but i hope people read
the book i mean it's a quick read it's
truly like you can read it in like an
hour or two but um
i hope people finish it and then go why
did i
ever give a give a [ __ ] about what
people think about me like why did i
ever care if someone stares at me
that means my body disrupted their life
enough that they needed to stop what
they were doing to look at me that means
my body
is powerful also everybody is
beautiful in its own way um and
everybody is different and
the world is already like really really
hard so why would you spend it hating
what you see in the mirror
that's like an extra layer of misery
have you you you've always been
um and i think it's a remarkable quality
you have but you just
you're always so comfortable with
yourself and i'm curious is that
who you've always been or did you have
to get to that place
um i've always been pretty comfortable
with myself
my mom used to call me tina because i
would scream
a lot like tina turner uh and i would
listen to tina turner and scream along
to that
and i've always kind of marched to my
own little drum beat
i don't know it's more fun to just
be like figure out who you are and just
be that why would
spending time trying to be somebody else
seems so
exhausting and also crazy yeah
yeah no i well um i
grew up not liking anything about myself
but why
conan you're tall that's luxurious
you have red hair how exotic you have
all your teeth what a treat
wait okay so you had three qualities you
liked about me
and one of them was i have all my teeth
that um nothing uh that did nothing to
me
but i want to ask you about you're on a
on a mission
to get people to embrace spandex let's
talk about that
why why spandex because spandex is
your friend like if you hold something
up and you're like i don't know if this
is gonna fit
pull it if it has spandex it probably
does fit
also if it's too tight who cares
people already know you're fat if you
wear bigger clothes people go look at
that fatty
if you wear tighter clothes people go
look at that fatty what's the difference
who cares so you think
everyone should be wearing spandex yes
conan i would like you to wear some
spandex
no okay it's not gonna be good it's not
gonna be good come on conan put on some
spandex
okay your logic nicole your logic
is just uh it's too powerful i say no
and you say
yes and so i'm going to do it um
not happy with my body and uh and
spandex
is going to bum a lot of people out so
but it might make three people happy
that's more than
you know it would do it would get laughs
which
in our profession that's gold we
love laughs because we're sad people on
the inside
i don't think you are i don't think
you're no i'm not i'm very happy
you have to check out this book it's
it's it's a great read and also
the pictures are fantastic uh it's by
nicole
it's very fat very brave and
uh a terrific book also uh
nicole you have a list of black owned
bookstores is that right that we want to
put up
yeah because uh it might be hard after
the pandemic for
black owned businesses to come back
especially since it's harder for us to
get
loans and whatnot so now is the time
to support yeah i also have a list of
black owned restaurants but i think it's
only in la
in my bio too okay all right well
like i say one of the things that i've
been picking up just in the last two
weeks of conversations
is it's it's not about uh
good uh i did three things and now
racism is gone we all know that's not
gonna happen it's about
uh living life uh being a little more
present being a little more
aware and doing the work every day in in
small ways
sometimes big way sometimes small ways
and supporting black owned businesses is
huge
huge it's a huge thing if you find a
black owned coffee shop in your
neighborhood
go there instead of starbucks it's not
that hard it's just
it's minor adjustments that you can make
in your life that will
deeply impact someone else's life
because that black owned business can
start generational wealth to give to
their kids
which is a beautiful thing yeah they're
also not going to be selling you a kenny
g
cd uh up there do i get something more
interesting
but i gotta say kenny g he got good hair
right he's got the long hair with the
socks long hair yeah yeah and he's fine
i've got no beef with him i'm just
saying i don't think
do you conan do you have beef with kenny
g yes i do
he took my woman oh no
i i i made that up but it could happen
he could my wife could run off with
kevin it could happen i don't think
it is so nice to see you abraham lincoln
behind you
uh yeah uh this is uh this is i've had
an abraham lincoln up here
for forever uh yeah i have a picture
it's the last photograph
ever taken of him uh
it's a rare outdoor photograph of
abraham lincoln
or you don't have nobody what's that
doesn't have a body
he had a body they just didn't have they
didn't have an iphone back then that
caught everything
so ah yeah so you know
whatever you know i'm you know i'm i've
got this place
conan how are you has anyone asked how
you are doing
no it hasn't really occurred to anybody
to ask me
how are you conan well i think
the last two weeks has been hardest on
me
and i'm shocked you're the first person
to notice it uh you're the first person
to reach out
but you know um that's how egotistical i
am
i somehow thought black lives matter was
all about me
i got confused that's what it means and
you're an ally
who's learning uh yeah well we all need
to learn
faster and more and more and faster but
um
you know i'm doing great and you know
what i'm very lucky because
uh and i'm very fortunate that i'm able
to keep doing this thing that i do
uh during this time of covid and on and
all this unrest and mostly because it
gives me
a lot of hope and joy like talking to
you today this is not a job touching
base with you
just makes me happy you just you bring
me a lot of joy every time you come on
the show
you're so naturally funny and you're
such a beautiful spirit
that that seeing you today makes me
happy
it just really makes me happy so conan
thank you
you're saving you're saving me right now
which is really what it's all about
i love how this was a nice compliment
that went right back to conan
i'm a genius at that
let me hold this up again because i want
to make people make sure people check it
out
very fat very brave get this book
and uh nicole thank you so much for
being here
and be well and i can't wait to see you
in person
samesies conan i adore you i'm happy
what's that mean conan you and i have a
chemistry
it just means uh it's undeniable you get
around me
and i get around you and you know what
i'm saying yeah
i can't wait to see you again conan
uh you're delightful all right
take care i love you and i'll see you
soon bye conan